it was november 20th 2019
and the helicopter circled far above in
the freezing wind of the antarctic
scp foundation site director jason
monroe looked down at the isolated
above-ground facilities of provisional
site 344-1
something about this place made him
nervous edgy
and for good reason between 2003 and
2019
29 mobile task force units and 73
members of d-class personnel had gone
missing here
and never been found monroe thought he
was here for a routine investigation
into negligence and mismanagement
but little did he know he was in for so
much more
this is the story of scp-5545
and one man's journey into his own worst
nightmare
literally but this nightmare began a
long time ago
300 years to be exact and like most
nightmares
it started as a dream that dream was one
of expansion
national powers across europe wanted to
be the first to conquer the globe and
expand
into new territories and sent countless
exploratory missions off into the
unknown to achieve this goal
any history book will tell you that the
first outsiders to lay eyes upon the
continent of antarctica did so in 1820
the reality is that the first ones to
get there actually landed
in the late 1700s the hapless explorers
ventured into mainland antarctica and
made base camps
before searching and digging for any
useful resources nearby
they came upon a strange discovery a
hallway
hidden beneath the ice not a passage in
the ice
but a true hallway complete with light
fixtures
the confused explorers ventured down
into these impossible hallways
and for many of them it would be the
last thing
they ever did no matter how long they
walked
it seemed like the hallways just kept
going as they continued to walk for
hours they hoped to find
something anything and eventually they
did
they pass from these hallways into
somewhere different altogether
and most of them were never heard from
again those who did manage to escape
often died or took their own lives soon
after
whatever it was they discovered down
there they didn't want to live with it
on their minds
it's believed that over 70 colonial
explorers disappeared or died this way
and that most who found these endless
hallways beneath the antarctic ice never
returned
the multiple anomalous objects and
phenomena that make up
scp-5545 came into the foundation's
hands several centuries later
on september 18 2003 when during an
expedition
into the antarctic they too found the
endless hallways
the foundation built provisional site
344-1 around them
hoping to safely seal them off from any
other unwitting antarctic
explorers or researchers but there was
something else
lurking beneath the ice in antarctica
something dangerous
the hallways were designated as
scp-5545-1
and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site
but soon scp-5545-2 was discovered
which resulted in the deaths of 16
researchers
so what exactly is 5545-2
it's an entity so volatile that even
knowing about it is considered to be a
containment breach
and as a result it's kept in provisional
site 344-2
unlike site 344-1 344-2
isn't a physical space it's conceptual
accessible only through the endless
hallways created with the express
purpose of keeping 5545-1
and 5545-2 separate why
because whenever the two come into
contact the result is 5545-3
the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways
in just 4 to six hours while the two are
apart though
5545-3 reverses but it always would take
just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of
infinite hallways scp-5545 has been
given the classification
safe wait we're dealing with a
mysterious and volatile anomaly that
claimed a huge number of lives and still
somehow eludes true foundation
understanding yet the official scp
foundation classification is
safe how could this be monroe was the
director of site 58
and was the definition of no nonsense
prior to taking the site director
position
he was a decorated member of mobile task
force eta 10 and helped contain
numerous ketter class anomalies he'd
been around the proverbial block when it
came to anomalous activity
and something about scp-5545 and the
management of provisional site 344
seemed awfully suspicious to him and he
had
questions like how such an unpredictable
anomaly could be declared
safe and why had there been such a lapse
of communication between the foundation
and dr gabriel reed
who'd been running the facility for the
past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious
scp-5545-2
monroe started to believe that something
terrible had happened at the site
and reed was covering it all up but to
find out for sure
he'd need to go to antarctica and
investigated himself
information about this supposedly safe
anomaly was highly classified
those without o5 clearance could face
termination for snooping
but that didn't scare jason monroe he
dealt with ketters before
he could deal with this or so he thought
monroe submitted a request and was
granted unanimous approval by the o5
council to travel to provisional site
344
and get to the bottom of this mystery he
took a chopper to the base soon after
armed with a concealed firearm and a
hostile meme detector
or hmd to test whether the base and its
staff had somehow fallen under a
hazardous memetic effect from scp-5545
he'd find the answers or die trying
the moment monroe arrived he couldn't
help but notice the strange way the
staff behaved
they seemed listless almost oppressive
when he showed his credentials to a
researcher
they simply said scp-5545-2 is contained
in site 344-2
his request to see dr reed that night
was denied
dr reed was busy he was told wait until
tomorrow
the next day dr monroe met with dr reed
but the results of the meeting were
underwhelming to say the least
just like the rest of the staff on the
site he seemed exhausted
as though he hadn't slept in days his
responses were quiet and evasive
and he refused to tell monroe anything
that wasn't in the official files
already
monroe ran the conversation through the
hmd and found
nothing out of the ordinary what was
going on here monroe was irritated
but not deterred nothing would stop him
from finding out the truth
the next day he flexed his o5
credentials and hacked into the base's
security system
this gave him access to cameras around
site 344-1
but more importantly there was a single
camera inside the mysterious site 344-2
jackpot but when he looked at it the
feed was an
entirely black screen with the words
scp-5545-2
is contained in site 344-2
the footage of the staff in 344-1 was
equally strange
the 18 employees on site all sat at
computer banks
with nothing but static playing on their
screens monroe kept digging though
and was able to hack into the security
footage of dr reed's office
as he watched he discovered a 15-minute
period where reed left the office each
day
he could use this brief window to break
in and collect more intel
on scp-5545-2
monroe was so wrapped up in the
investigation that he almost forgot the
more immediate danger around him
and nearly wandered into one of the
endless hallways of 5545-1 by mistake
he made a note to be more careful in the
future his first attempt at breaking
into dr reed's office didn't produce
many answers
one piece of evidence was a blurry
picture of what looked like a mobile
task force entering a 5545-1 hallway in
the dark
another was a spreadsheet featuring all
the personnel living
or dead who worked at the site but one
name
and the details of whether this person
was alive or dead
was completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind
o5 clearance if monroe wanted the
answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare
one that had plagued him since he joined
mtf editten he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry
and the woman looked afraid as he
approached the fireplace
the ceiling extended infinitely up into
the darkness
suddenly the zombie-like body of a
teenage girl appears in the fireplace
hanging from a long thread her eyes look
furious and full
of rage and monroe somehow knows that
he's the reason for her hurt
when he steps into the fireplace in this
dream she attacks him
the two intertwine and they burn forever
the one difference was that in this new
iteration of the dream
he blinked upon entering the fireplace
and suddenly he was in the hallway
he awoke sure that something was
terribly wrong here
but he couldn't give up now the next day
dr monroe broke into reed's office and
made a horrifying discovery
he found files indicating that dr reed
was knowingly sending mobile task forces
and d-class personnel into the infinite
hallways of 5545-1
to their doom he also found evidence
that reed and the researchers had been
spying on him
somehow intercepting copies of the notes
he had been taking
that's when dr reed entered the office
and interrupted him monroe panicked and
drew his weapon
holding the doctor at gunpoint he was
breaking so many foundation rules
but right now he feared for his life the
doctor seemed unbothered by monroe's
threats though
he told monroe that everything was going
to plan and that he should go back to
his room
monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards might burst in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense
he worried he was going insane perhaps
the only way to find answers was to go
even deeper to risk it all and venture
through the endless hallways to find
scp-5545-2 himself
and finally discover what this thing
actually was
monroe left his room and stepped into
one of the endless hallways of 5545-1
that was located just across from his
dorm
he found that it was a hallway like all
the others on site
plain concrete worn of age with simple
light fixtures on the walls
he walked for hours recording with a
concealed device
the light suddenly went out leaving him
in complete darkness
when they flicked back on he was in a
very different environment
a grand old carpeted hallway the kind
you'd see in an old mansion
he broke into a cold sweat what was so
familiar about this place
he kept walking racked with terror until
this new hallway finally led him to the
place he'd been seeking
site 344-2 the domain
of 5545-2 it was a large poorly lit
room filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end
it was the exact same room for monroe's
dream
with one horrifying difference monroe
noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling
and when he looked up to find its source
he screamed
there were hundreds of bodies hanging
and swinging from the ceiling above him
everyone who scp-5545-2 had ever killed
including mtf members d-class personnel
and
even the colonial explorers from
hundreds of years before
and all of them were him every single
one
they had his face and there hanging in
the middle of the room at ground level
was the body of a teenage girl the one
from his dream in that moment he finally
recognized her
she was the girl he killed the first him
hundreds of years ago much like monroe
you're probably wondering
what is going on here thanks to
declassified communication between dr
reed and the o5 council
we can tell you jason monroe was a man
who's been reincarnated hundreds of
times over the last 300 years
ever since he murdered a teenage girl a
girl named
emily his daughter this murder sparked
the existence of scp-5545
as an eternally reoccurring punishment
for his crimes
since figuring this out the foundation
has kept tabs on monroe's reincarnations
whether they're mtf members d-class
personnel or
even site directors they see to it that
these reincarnations always find their
way
back to 5545 to take his punishment
and prevent the infinite hallway
expansion that threatens to destroy the
world
it's a plan everyone is in on everyone
except him
but every time he enters that nightmare
haunting room
it all comes rushing back in that moment
though
he knew his crying and he somehow knew
how many times this punishment had
unfolded for him
he now had two choices repent and accept
the punishment again
or leave and activate 5545-3
potentially allowing the endless tunnels
to expand across the world
like his many predecessors monroe made
the decent choice
he accepted his punishment and allowed
his own string to coil around him as the
lights in the room went
off one by one leaving only darkness
jason monroe that version of him at
least
was never seen again but the scp
foundation is already eyeing up his next
reincarnation
and preparing to let this twisted cycle
play out
all over again and while you're here why
not check out scp-066 eric's toy
and scp-035 the possessive mask
for more mysterious anomalies from the
scp foundation